In this video,
we'll look at a common way of initializing
the parameters of a neural network.
So we're not the final step in,
uh,
our recipe for obtaining
the whole cicastic gradient
descent training algorithm
for neural net. Uh, so I have to
look at the initialization methods.
So how do we initialize the,
uh,
initial value of all of our parameters,
all of our,
a hidden layer weights and biases as
well as the output weights and biases?
Okay. Well, um, typically, uh,
we often first initialized
devices to a zero. Uh,
so we don't express any
preference for the, uh,
hidden units taking values that
are above or below, uh, you know,
closer to the saturation point,
the lower saturation point or the
higher saturation point. Um, if,
uh,
if you're using a,
a sigmoid activation function and a,
if you would like most hidden
needs to be close to zero,
taps us more sparsity in the
activation of, uh, your, uh,
layers. Uh, it's sparsity something
we haven't discussed so much, uh,
in later videos we'll talk about
that and why that might be desirable.
But if you do this,
then you might want to initialize the
biases to a large negative violin.
Like say, you know, the bias could
initially be minus 10 plus, you know,
the activation that would
give you the value of a unit.
And so because of this, uh, if this
term is not too large, initially,
most units would be close to zero.
So that's one way of initializing and
neural network in a situation where it's
initially sparse in its hidden
activations. Uh, but, uh,
that's for special cases where
you think that's a good idea,
just in general a good recipes
to just initialized to zero. Um,
now for the weights, uh,
well let's see. First, uh,
could we initialize them to zero?
Well, uh, if we use the, uh,
tench activation function,
we can actually show that all gradients
will be zero at the first time.
You compute your gradients. And
so, uh, if the grain size zero,
then you're updating your weights with
me in the direction that the vector of
zero, so you're not
changing the weights. Uh,
and so this essentially corresponds
to settle point. You've converged,
quote unquote, and uh, you can't
move away from that initialization.
So that's obviously a
bad idea. Um, well, okay,
could we,
should I initialize all the weights to
non zero value but to exactly that same
non zero value,
but it's also a bad idea.
And that's because in that case we can
show that all hidden units in all layers,
uh,
we'll always behave the same.
All the Hinns will compute
exactly the same, uh, uh,
activation function and a,
essentially all of the units there are
connections with the layer below will
always stay the same. And,
uh, and intuitively though,
we want the neural net where we have
different than Munis that do different
things. And so we need to break the
initial symmetry that we've, uh,
that would have enforced if we had used
the same identical value for all weights
of all the units.
And so the recipe that people use,
the usually follow is that they're
going to samples the cast actually the
initial value for all the weights.
Uh,
and one thing that we propose here is
to use a uniform distribution in some
interval minus B two B. So,
uh, around centered at zero.
And the value that suggested that we
propose here is the square root of six
divided by the square root of the sum
of the number of units in layer k and
number of units in layer
came on this one. Uh, and um,
so that might seem like a strange
formula. Uh, let's first no, this,
that, um, one of assemble
around zero because we want
the initially small weights.
We want to start with a simple neural
network that's not to nonlinear.
And because the probability that
I'll weights are sampled, you know,
uh, get a initial value that's exactly
the same as essentially zero. Uh,
then we can break symmetry.
So now each in the unit is going to be
initialized with a slightly different, uh,
initials, state initial
set of weights. Um,
so other values for B could work well,
this is just one proposal
and this isn't like,
this isn't an exact science determining
good initialization for their own that,
uh, the parameters of the neural
net can look at this paper.
This is where I got this
formula here. And, uh,
they can show under certain conditions
that the hidden layer values at the end
layer activations and also the
gradients are back propagated,
will tend to have a
similar ranges of values,
similar variants across the
different layers. And that's
something that, uh, means,
uh,
so if you have very big gradients at say
the top hidden layer in small green and
set the Laura hidden layer,
then uh,
intuitively this means that the top in
layer we'll train much faster because
it's,
it's pushed further away from its current
value because the gradients are bigger
than the, uh, lower hidden there
if they had those smaller gradient.
And so they tried to correct for this at
least initially by using this value in,
they show under certain conditions
that this is well behaved. All right,
so this is a very reasonable,
uh,
initialization recipe to use and
I encourage you to use that. And,
uh, but, uh, as I stated,
there are other papers that might suggest
other values which might work well.
One thing that she would want to do is
perhaps use always the same formula,
but at least try different
seed for how you, Jay,
for your random number generator
that generates, uh, uh,
numbers between minus B and B.
And so we'll try different values and
then see which one works better, uh,
as a solution for, in terms of the quality
of the neural net you get. All right,
so this is a good recipe to follow
for initializing your neural network.